he conveyed Ian Desmond members offices
this is the Oxford District Council
Development Committee Chairman college
seniors I do have some housekeeping to
get through first of all there's an
emergency evacuation announcement should
we be required to evacuate the building
would you please leave the building by
the nearest available exit to the
chamber now obscenely quieten be a
public car park to the side of this
isn't sweet please not deny your
evacuation or to collect environs please
do not return to the building until
people permission to do so by council
song please note that this meeting will
be all he recorded in that state would
members which industry please announce
themselves I filed it might call them
apologies for absence for counselor
Chris Lang has the Terry catwalk Council
heavily in the Council of Georgie are
bothering of this castle haley
substitute pellets were
but calves are cut one cancer gene money
for counseling screen cat Wesson and for
counselor the honor Joe muppet
and only the stay in the city for cancer
Odin I'll be above the five cats item
councillor Burton eps estates a person
theory of care solutions if I support
this my foods only 70 or just tender you
sleep on it for the present position up
without his life hopefully dress before
septic however you a call me Jeff can
move my priority pass this normally have
apparently it is called the application
in minutes of the site that haul road
and the whole purpose of the application
was rotation from the affordable housing
but percentages from 8222 7230 know
where another hole is the original
application that was granted there is no
that application there get full
may mention i would like that noted it
was a challenge from a beautiful
facility for first-degree through your
molecule for survivors on the torso and
casting his test yes you tricked your
community property yes yes we love that
german and i have motions in ways we
ministered cousins intensity lights but
emotional man this can
well I do have an objection to how its
minuted and I have raised it with
officers who haven't come back to me I
would like to make an addendum just to
note that the purpose of that
application being good for us was to
change the refuse affordable rented
section and to increase the social
housing share ownership sector from 8222
7230 generating the correct procedure is
that if you want to amend the minute you
that you need to publish in florida
segment and amenity river
we should be made just just so
accurately we don't the decisions that's
permanently first edition decision that
was made and it refers to the report
where buy orders containing
18 to 20 how that happens to me if we're
allowed lights are so low that that is
is now too okay I'll second that
chairman that's the mr. Mason secondly
it would choose members please indicate
those in favor of the amendments can you
repeat it in the pc just as easy night
so did you want me to appreciate or two
I think it might be first tell me from
yourself I love left my notes at home
you're going to have to forgive me i'm
slightly bullion this but what the main
thing is just to know that the reason
for the application men refer back to
it's better than committing was to
change the affordable housing
percentages from 18 to 20 to 17 to 30 as
all I most intimate relationship scores
just note that alteration what resistant
agree with that you three people don't
am content okay thank mr. Chen
we don't take anything that the midst of
the seven th September Lucien Lucien
trivia are accepted and approved by
members with the amendment to this three
sets of a mini degree and then we're
going to redo the 17th of 10 minutes of
a true record safety Bible there's an
aesthetic yeah regredi similarly four
minutes of the 30 from sep tember
devotes a green gnosis tree record great
thank you the minutes of the 13th
october we've accepted no maintenance
and tsunamis that also group that's up
if I projects like mr. J mother from not
noted that we have 30 minutes to thank
you
no it's nice and followed the
declarations of interest other income in
various ways accessible
make sure it is pertinent to note that I
am a member all right town councils but
take no part in any of their planning
natives take a guess of all the other
solutions just are they up to vote in
their instruments okay okay capsule rtd
only interested in layer that's the
person so I was inspecting the purchase
I I've got interest as a member right
town council hopes i had a pecuniary
interest in height and weight and
worldly the chamber with it that's
especially emotional I have not seen you
in crystal I'm remember the tell me how
to i do not sit on lieutenant committee
but that's enough DHS member Brady town
council walkouts of jersey okay so Jack
to talk again
just uncounseled that and just to
clarify believe it's a displacement
ladies out right item 6 had been issued
for this meeting that I understand did
lead developer requested anything
everything so get a move on to Russian
seven cited editor for orbital bone in
hockley offices thank you Joe this
application is sign of a president with
all which is located laterally is
located in the red line that you see
there the group of class review and
thank you where the cursor is pointing
it's some 800 meters or so from
combining the high road at the top it's
contained you'll see waves here Pink
buildings there it's tight area of some
foot 12 hectares intralase under
application site the prison coating last
2013 their phone died which is bull bull
which sits in these of open grounds
between mighty complex of buildings
where the cursor is now the terrace of
houses which is an outside of the site
on the other side there's a single track
remember that leads down to that site it
makes the junction with high road at the
top and that tracking is also a public
footpath through to a point we see the
blue line crossing the site about a
third of the way down from the top but
then another by forty nine o'clock the
site towards the right so
next screen you can see and back in room
the air alongside the access track and
the foreground era we forward on as a
number of substantial trees which are
now subject to the tree preservation
order the application of the sea is 460
12 inches in outline form all matters
reserve other than the axis so that is
the appearance of the buildings and the
layouts the landscaping of style are all
reserve matters should permission be
granted for a subsequent part2
application it was automatic application
but tonight as an outline application
with looking at critical of the
acceptability of the development
together with the access to the site
besides in flood zone one where the
environment agency's I agree development
should be corrected the error please
Chris now there's two main issues which
is to divert in the green belt because
the cycling brito Norma today's
prevention of reading of it the
government policy has some time now
allowed situations where you have a
well-developed part back and larger
cycles in this case that part is
occupied by compression abilities he's
allowed to be drinking our alternative
design in this case housing that means
national policy perspective you vote in
your seat tonight we concentrated on the
hard surface areas and the building's
themselves in that area still ages
he's not inappropriate development the
applicant does not have to demonstrate
very special circumstances hello matters
of scarlet appearance are not for
consideration yeah it does have to help
us with an idea of the sort of quantum
and the arrangement of the buildings and
he can advise us that he expects the
development you can see there which is
indicative played the houses would be up
to two and a half stories in Heights
that members and we've rented normal
incorporate some kind of door miss rooms
in the roof design and up to an overall
height of around nine and a half meters
now the largest buildings that the store
on the earlier lay out their prison
movie are up to three stories with 12
meters overall now with your policy pm10
that normally requires that development
be located regional postal services in
this case societies just a bit further
away relatively near but somewhat
distant depending on on the adjoining
senator pattern is not within a hundred
makes perfect sense I've doctors source
acidity five batters over white you're
seeking from the result that obviously
take of you that warning for residential
use the site we potentially has some
kind of commercial application which in
turn would bring with other problems and
suddenly lack of fit with the
residential uses of the access the word
is the sensitivity to the enjoyment and
a popular site so unbalanced obviously
edge who uses the most preferred in
planning terms if I redevelop in this
site there would be no significant
impact on the merging of the settlements
with Bailey and hopefully the site is
already development the prison use so
you're really swapping out the buildings
and activities in your forum for a
different type of buildings and built
for its own sprawl as such an applicant
is concentrating on the development
areas including the surfaces outside the
main security facing that most of the
done you see there is contained within
the existing security fencing the outer
one of which would be retained in the
cinemas as part of a buffer management
obviously then even that the development
you see we've not conflict with the
approach valuation mindset and the
outline for this application requires
that a number of conditions to the right
shape and SI toos earth matters and
members we'll see they're set out in the
recommendation typically degree before
you members will also note the
application position has changed on the
provision of affordable housing when
this application is submitted
development advice favored something
from vacant building credit which was a
racial rationale based on the floor
space to completely buildings demolished
as opposed
new zealand ltd come in and based on
that at that time the applicant wasn't
required info you provide affordable
housing the government's hadn't even
challenged to that advice and control
that so during the time of the
application has been with us tenders
need a physician and now according to
your policies including the provision of
thirty-five percent affordable housing
now there is a Latin I up you'll see
that it shows a relatively low density
of sort of family size have an itch
mostly detachment gardens to appreciate
the formal housing those are probably
find a smaller households so you would
expect that the matted application show
why as well in mix in order to
accommodate that you're super Liverpool
counselor in designer pages that as well
instead of the layout agency they would
you know immunity reserve battle
application for greater spread of
glowing types now the other concern of
the stages with height ways you'll see
that the application comes with by
transporting assessments as analyze the
impact of this city in comparison with
recognized data for the use of the site
of remains
nice fire to the prison and the
applicants are assessed in terms of the
development for 75 units and opposite we
would have x the most ability robustness
to this game the county highway
authority have considered those
assumptions and have an objection to
write the impact the farm that the plan
that you see their shows alterations the
outcome proposes from any vehicle access
to web presences the bottom left hand
corner of your screen assume the road
would be widened until with six point
one four meters to our two peoples to
pass and in the junction of the top onto
high road greatly widened see there in
the shade of grey some of us hopefully
be able to see that the existing road
track is in a broom changing color the
proposed changes of england great as
part of that the applicants negotiation
with the landowner who is variable to
this would recites the existing hedge we
understand that can be planted
subjective management can be recited in
the garden in the reduced garden area
and visibility would be improved as you
can towards the railing here highways
have prior to the application being
submitted have been in discussions with
the applicants to achieve this you'll
then see the middle section of the Tory
and the continuation of the roadway
south which is largely I wanted you'll
see the blue patch line to begin to the
very bottom of the screen they were
assessed self-image we'll see once again
the road is wide and which continues on
the farm image near the title box on the
on the dory I see again the road is wide
and then you'll see that announce a line
of a footpath at least to be created
around
room down alongside the calibrate to the
site these works recruit access to the
site Tara million crime by the county
highway authority will see this
recommendation are conditions and
requirements and even bring water to
super does it include chairman there is
therefore the continent I will not be
inappropriate in the green belt is
acceptable no material addition proposed
in the sea and analysis on higher
grounds now since the report was written
we've had one additional comment to see
representation I'm a resident at 25 ppl
chance why and which I'll breathes it on
the whole library most of the people
living locally to forward call will be
glad this area becomes housing I think
on the proposed modifications for the
high-rise building for my injunction
when you eliminate most people currently
for access attention should be paid to
the bushes on the south side of the
junction are currently but up to the
edge of the roadway as a the moment they
prevent a clear view to the south in
10-13 or without liked to have commented
on the plans but it is almost impossible
the way that I presented online one
other matter chairman that the heads of
conditions that will see in the
recommendation they speak a number of
them new squeak do having sufficient
details prior to commencement the work
yet
has a question back the light of
government advice which says that there
should be the minimum number of
conditions that require details big
green ry prevent commencement and
because there's two sets to this
development there is the demolition side
and then there is the development itself
officers agreeable to the applicants
request to revise a number of those
conditions just changing the wording the
subject matter is not an issue but to
require kinds of things help we
submitted and agreed not so much before
the commencement permission under the
moment requires in black man state and
other matters to be submitted before the
actual residential development start
rather than the demolition process
itself on that basis general the
recommendations approval as I just
mentioned you will set out a little they
give strokes we have to see whose cancer
sorry miss Cathy fallacies preparing
antigen and seconds ago is the date they
insisted jet is that this category
careful with this
I'll give you another five minutes only
one which girl is actually chair and
members of the faculty we fill in dorsey
officers recommendation of approval the
redundant former prison which closed
over two and a half years ago is a
significant brownfield site the presence
closure was a result of the government's
wider modernization program to improve
the operational efficiency of the prison
estate the principle of reasoning this
land and delivering new housing is fully
supported by both national and local
policies in particular in context of
Greenbelt policy the redevelopment would
need meet the necessary policy tests of
appropriate development in terms of
visual impact the proposals would
deliver positive beneficial change a
local landscape setting the reduction
pulsates height sound and mass compared
to that existing prison complex and the
additional landscaping and gardens
creators will reduce the overall level
of hard sanding and provide additional
benefits to biodiversity and increase
permaban areas of evidence and Amity
report number of the statutory
consultees have raised any technical
Jackson's further demonstrating and
opposes are an effective and efficient
use of the site in terms of assessing
traffic impact it's important to
appreciate that when operational the
present attracted a significant number
of trusted site the number of South
employer is only 200 with an operating
capacity for over 230 inmates on a
weekly basis visiting hours would see a
further two hundred
traveling to the site the traffic
analysis work which is supported by the
counts counties highway engineers
identifies the previous prison operation
is comparable to the equivalent at 75
dwellings this is above the 60 proposed
the proposed a large disability space
the junction with high road and
provision of the footway was
significantly improve the current
highway arrangement an additional land
hasn't been secured to undertake the
necessary works whilst we acknowledge
some residents contested the mystery of
Justices registered title associated
with the verge along the eastern side of
orale this area is outside the planning
application red line and doesn't form
part though development proposals as
such it is not an interior consideration
the assessment the application the
applicants have really engage of the
local community particularly those in
encloses the site including individual
meetings aspects of detailed design
including the need to accommodate
additional power parking space for them
has been discussed and agreed with
officers that the vast majority of trees
have obtained as well as the central
green area which by play space
facilities the site's redevelopment
makes a significant contribution is win
for housing sites in eaton core
strategies housing targets and the
government's key policy objects in
boosting the overall supply of housing
and delivering new homes the sites
redevelopment in there for a system
reducing pressure on other or
constrained line with
district yeah like Otis committee
started demolition and remediation as
soon as possible and suggested supplier
of memories the post conditions to
undertake these enabling works in
bringing the site forward the site is
also closed lip locate the site is also
located in close proximity to rayleigh
and hockley over t1 settlements which
incentive to have the greatest range of
services and considering the most
disabled locations further benefits of
the scene include the investment and
refurbishment board hall that's
preserving and significantly enhancing a
locally listed heritage assess the
transfer of Whitbread woods some 6.6
hectares into public ownership walnut
for community use with a new public
footpath providing a direct linking
property roots creation of over 150 jobs
in the construction in the supply chain
and being located in zone one the
science the lowest probability of
Fleming and reduction holds only in
creation gardens and landscaping will
increase the parable areas that's
improving existing surface water runoff
the applicant has also agreed a full
section 106 package in delivering the
necessary and appropriate infrastructure
to support the development including
contributions to education health from
the full thirty five percent affordable
housing provision in summary the
proposals are fully compliant forest
development plan policies and deliver
clear social economic and environmental
benefits in supporting in supporting
sustainable development of jack
is we therefore urge members to support
their offices in the regulation for
approval nice little Thank You mr. David
days you will also have five minutes
I'll tell you what let's go
good evening to you ladies and gentleman
convincing and one of the residents are
forward all Lane one of the houses there
and there are few to the other residents
support or lame or so here as well my
objection to the proposed developments
aboard all late is as a residence over
with all that I have you lived in
Oakland for a number of years and and
had to deal with the rose and the
traffic and since we've been there which
is generally increased now has been
mentioned by my associate the the
Department of Justice has from each of
the residence on the left-hand side of
board Elaine coming from ray bounced
also have been former prison and main
claim ownership of the grass verge and
the pavements all the way down the east
side of the lane and they use developers
information which we as a residence are
disputing and claim for unlawful
possession is currently in legal hands
all appalled laying itself is a single
narrow lane it's access is not wide
enough to allow one car in NY the
powerhouse and when the prison was there
the traffic generally the staff went
into works are they all follow
themselves in and when they came out
they all came out again visiting time
was generally on when he was a ladies
prison was generally on a Sunday and
again was all traffic going in my way
and then coming out another way perhaps
and offers been earlier indicated when
it was dealing with immigrants it was
very little traffic going in and out
apart from natural son and so at that
point that the road could just
out saying out sort of traffic and as a
resident acts away for a number of cars
to go past I can certainly talk with a
personal point of view of having to way
there for the traffic depending on road
currently doesn't allow for delivery
lorries to deliver home and allow other
traffic to policy nowadays you want to
have something delivered to you always
seems to turn up in a 7-ton lorry and
not each of the houses down bored with
all night can the lorries and apache
turning staff and holds up the traffic
in London the road the developers have
indicated a footpath in their players
now we've looked at this and the mission
there's just not the room for a road and
a footpath safely for walkers unhindered
and a number of feet will come down
there walk their dogs as well but moving
on to the approach from the high road
traffic is waiting to come in to forward
all lane they see at the top of all
would hallway and in this area allows
currently at the moment one possibly two
cards are already there or a big van one
vehicle sits there and however it's my
opinion adding the number of houses and
cause a number of traffic and that the
divide
proposing that we love emails traffic
wishing to come in to forward all lame
that were then stick the top and bottom
line which isn't big enough anyway and
on the high road and particularly at
that's on rush outside it will just fit
complete sense Allah especially about
the trappings trying to come out the boy
all day this will just call slow the
congestion now the number of vehicles
using a high row and that has been
mentioned in reports we've seen the
numbers and at one of our neighbors has
actually set and counter the traffic and
we feel that this figure that has been
submitted is inaccurate sort of
incorrect and we'd ask for a total
independence report on the actual
numbers and the type the London that and
the reports be done and in actual busy
times not in the middle of the night all
around school holidays or occasional
quite kiddies their alternative options
of the approach and humble tentative
options but these have seen being used
I'm going forward hall and option and a
part on board more lame we want these
other options to be looked at and we
wish the plane could be considered by
the developer the infrastructure of the
hotkey road and his traffic cannot
currently handle a tragic situation let
alone adding many more cars and delivery
lorries we would ask that this issue is
addressed first of all before adding
further traffic problems to an existing
traffic situation in conclusion although
it set there will be a development on
the site of the old prison the lane can
certainly not sustaining the amount of
traffic that the development and over 60
houses will generate however it's a
planning department looks at the other
options has access backwards and
forwards I'm sure we could come to
something that we all
happy with this who let members now the
arrangements have been agree for all of
seeking other completes the committee
members to do prefer status and
substitute amongst them will favor the
war men or neighbors if they're actually
I'm a refugee and subsequently I will
allow the nominee the 60 members to
sleep if they have a board member cusan
civet e and if they in companies and
there are the smack to see i'll also try
and commit that's awesome members should
be aware that there will be five minutes
maison are seeking for each of them as
they are called so given what I've just
said a little cool pencil a too though I
believe wishes to sleep first I'm also
communication from cancer step toes and
council see the capsule warm captain
Alistair Lacey it helps a lovely talk
about the author
so guess is Julie yes sir thank you mr.
Jim I have misgivings only access the
ball with hormone into 60 homes
potential of up to 180 vehicles the idea
was put forward is going to whine about
674 meters of road through wicked
through wit basis 6 140 meters he says
he's going to widen the road from South
launched back to the site four-point 800
meters and he's going to create a
pedestrian a right way that areas were
problem aids these are a single track
bottleneck from South launched who
regrets or fails that is that
centimeters 50 meters but it's a fair
bottleneck and that concerns me by
vehicles coming and going soft and
reversing will be problematic and there
will be quite mark pollution for the
residents whose properties are adjacent
road a particularly South knowledge now
a previous planning application i think
if i saw was refused i think as the ted
homes and because of the inadequacy of
orbital day that was one brand reviews
of refusal there was no footpaths from
marion house to the junction with rocky
road how can that be safe
60 home 50 children and I said that the
the traffic will be no worse than the
present traffic I think that's probably
disingenuous now since March 2013 there
has been no prison 2006 to 2013 with
failed immigrants who Sanders were
predominantly abroad and visitors were
relatively few now visiting took place
same with the way it was a ladies prison
I was on Sundays mostly and the shift
hours of the staff were at odd hours and
suddenly vehicles were predominately
going the same way with the change of
shift with visitors so you have the
problem of vehicles come and go in the
school this will happen predominantly in
60 honey rush hours the comings and
goings will be intense long single track
run of 70 meters 80 meters my contention
is that this axis where is inadequate by
the junction with all with all laying
with hockey road is also problematic in
russia house it's extremely difficult or
exit or enter balls all day and if it is
determined right in the hockey road from
the line q into tonys ball with all
learning from hockey row will aggravate
long tails back tail back to brush out
and cause them I'm sorry
copies of big words we none can huge
amount of traffic need that salad rush
as a nice instruction with the structure
of the long tailbacks do together I'm
telling right from bored all day and
hopefully roads right-hand bend your
left which makes the maneuver hazardous
also estimation determine the lack of 12
secondary school places needed
understands can be a deficit of 398
places by 2018-19 for secondary school
places what is going to happen first
others living in the new cousins unable
to secure places for this development
mr. chair I'm concerned there is no
corresponding wrote in the structural
second boost all places furthermore
there is no on the hockey brokers no
foot path to the bus stop on the rainbow
side of the road there for children how
to cross the road and cross again that
is pretty hazardous as I protest I throw
myself for numerous occasions so it look
freezing so mr. Chairman I have some
misgivings over slamming application
thank you ticket it presses some sorry
episode 03
some point of clarification if I'm
ranking officers first of all that start
with the drawing that is on the screen
at the moment and the win running comes
out onto the main road they're counting
there's an access to the property of
inquiries that comes directly over there
back in will that be maintained you
understand the access stated since the
excess but the size does have another
access down yeah so the religious Nexus
will change but it will be graphically
in sideways just one factor oh that's
lionstone's ok now the haste of these
unlock the borders along the actual main
roads along the side of a commodity well
that's the one that causes a lot of
problem we've seen around the corner and
it will not be relocated as well no
chair of the idea is that it could be
like what we call face back it's rather
than allowed to spread some so we cut
back the ones have been replanted is
along the lane
okay I finally on this Rory the
objective scope out a full park around
along the side of food Nana be right
there hey quite a now I can't like you
how come we haven't either postal pass
chair is on the lower part know who
these people come there's no existing
footpath way through this is a shared
surface gym okay and my final point
plantation is offered the main drawing
of the lamp besides if you could make
this now I believe there are a number
listed buildings we either site could
you point out those those balloons chair
the only building of interest
historically is this one kids would hold
which has been subject to extensive
observations not statutory listening
there are the building though here is a
colossal which is big emotions for the
1960s building in the building's
themselves in 1960s the listed buildings
are back up the top here where we've
sorted at a single track record isn't
about four or five there sat emotional
ties I think with breads is the one with
the hedgerows between Messiah tea those
are older buildings because she turn
into the name is a number of mr.
buildings there but the only one of a
summer crusted over in bold she's not
this on your local East so the ambition
would be to keep it it's not like
statutory gym
but if it allows some additional tom
early because they know that the
questions that you call it also
immediately but generally seeking google
drive txt five minutes gets it ng
chairman in the discussion that I've
heard so far the principle of the
housing on the site doesn't seem to be a
concern it doesn't concern me and I
think that the detail it immaculate will
allow us to come to scientific including
that it clearly is around the access
arrangements that we have some some
concerns I don't know what the standard
required for the access road is whether
there is an ambition for that we purge
it to be upgraded to an adoptable
standard or not but if I could recur
27.6 not 57.6 9-iron 17 on highways I
think that's where we're a lot of our
discussion needs to focus around clearly
you can't deny or ignore the use of fear
what was happy was a prison it was used
all hours of the day of the day night
but item 17 says the prior to the
commencement of the development accepts
to the demolition remediation well I
feel that the moment this development
sauce we will be potentially at very
high levels of usage that will continue
through the construction phase that move
into the occupation phase I think that
given the variety of concerns that are
around
and the nature of the activity that will
be taking place I feel that the item 17
needs to be from the commencement of all
works on something and I do I'm almost
minded to move that as a as an amendment
that work does it do so just yet the VIP
access down the road I don't know what
we've got any pictures of that to see
whether there are passing places we've
got the dimension of the width of the
pavement but I just want to be confident
that that isn't compromising the use of
that that rose within the boundaries of
the site plan that were popular de
Flores I wonder whether I get that
passing comment on that back offices
thank you restrict agenda for sure we
don't have picture but there are passing
places further down along this area here
currently to drop into the site go up
through the trees
okay it's me right up this is what
over/under say madam about guess it
would take a chair much what counselor
Smith has just said I myself will making
notes on with regards to the fact that
there seems to be a sentence that the
new estate however in shape would be
acceptable it's the access which is the
9 line of contention and I think that
again is castor Smith falls up with
regard to commencement of of works the
excess should be an absolute priority
bearing in mind the works traffic that
will be going in there also major
consideration for some sort of possible
traffic traffic signaling at that area
because I know that that particular I
wrote is extremely well used and we have
senior schools there at the Junior small
there but there's lots of traffic that's
going backwards and forwards at critical
times and maybe also there should be
something that in regards to when that
access is started there should be some
sort of condition to avoid works traffic
accidents on
so I believe that needs to people of
China quite seriously I also never want
to come to the disputed areas which
again is highlighted obviously it has
been brought up that this locals problem
go forward the development until this is
settled and possibly is nothing to do
committing at this moment but it is an
interesting point whereby the widening
of this road could be a major problem if
that dispute is actually seven and that
something is the highlighted because i
believe the access is the problem and if
that's the my problem in my opinion that
needs to be sorted out try to any
development Thank You general but if
there's a war situation about a little
energy santini and accommodations in the
under strict into the reason activity
and methods for hours I think Pauline
two sessions though obviously on her now
and we would rush report former that we
do remember finishing 17 and to actually
and remove the words accepted in the
derivation of vacation except in fact
that place only vehicles are using that
junction
p that convulse waiting heavily and
always have a forward activity center
point of virtually any London starts and
that society already commenced
themselves that that is is actually
performing at that point and also a
condition that would actually restrict
and deliveries not obviously sidewalks
delivery vehicles drive a size four
hours so that once you see to some
additional condition related to shipping
deliveries outside so well so they can
clarify some wells and also ensuring
that 30-17 is amended to and always
except for missionary mutations that
basically get that dirty rooms
[ __ ]
just listen ocean Thank You chairman and
not surprisingly i was over last some
questions about access and i won't pick
up some points that need enter these
folks brought up dimension other options
I haven't seen those in the presentation
you also mentioned an independent report
on the highways traffic conditions and
its capacity and selector that my
question which is about the passing
points and we've been it will be on this
and I think they're going to be vital so
how many other are there and how many
vehicles do they actually support if
it's cans latest return rather than 18 I
don't know how you're going to be trying
to move one time whether it can we hope
you one direction or the other I doubt
but I'd be really really interesting to
know how that's been assessed and to
allow many people in my five minutes
I'll carry on asking the questions let
the questions come later and we all
known as a housing plan bill which is
currently in embassage and and I would
like to know whether a particular aspect
of planning warehousing valley girl will
affect this application when it to come
back for detailed planning in particular
the the press reporting this morning
there would be measures to bring forward
two hundred thousand starters that of
twenty cent discount the young
first-time buyers which will create a
special presumption in favor of such
homes so my question on that to the
offices is to ask whether our detailed
planning if that bill is passed will
that become a new man
for us to consider what's the country
technologies an application relates to
to plan a like and 76 joints and that's
all that we can determine inventiveness
today and any changing attestation of
course and the point of which the
applications determined obviously we
have to make assessment of that without
only an hour an application or reserve
multiphysics of learnings any a
different developer to decline and the
further consent in terms of the design
of the highway obviously that would be a
letter for every the highway 13 system
for counsel and obviously we will and
will expect a developer to work in on
this kind of council to provide notice
acceptable in terms of a separate
settlement the assessment of the highway
activity on this site was assessed by
professionals acta suspense council with
professional submission from the
developer themselves and obviously the
works of carry the work that has fallen
from that has given the conditions are
sent out in a report from necessary
council which ends up with a fitted
which sets out as our page 7.69 which
relate to works you Jaron Lane
improvements and obviously discharge of
surface water additional condition
following discussion of notice today
lexingto efficient restricting
deliveries to ensure that the road
network isn't impeded that application
and also effective in Chameli gives
coastal erosion
I didn't hear about number of passing
points and the number of vehicles that
can accommodate champ chairman this is
one you can see on this plan but it sees
elongating you get several cars or a
large Laurie in there a straight run
planning be a cop remember great show
position also my point of view the
design of that Lane will be an infection
as if council requirements obviously and
we will have access to to view that and
with no improvements at that point
obviously that is for us to discharging
any place on a plane authority so
obviously have will work with hope the
developer works hand-in-hand with am
with expert counsel and also have to
ensure that that and those improvements
actually improve the activity on that
side Ralph and actually impede any
further reminding the fact that the
activity even though it seemed to have
fallen away at a time yet sea levels
could have picked up at any point to
level such looking pretty different
types of the prison was to learn thank
you such as already there are such as
motion
thank you Jim I'm going to just have one
point of clarification in relation to
the second be places and Paige sent
applied to two people I think white
enter be fair even if I could just read
that and this supposed to mobile is
impatient in a lot of technique grouped
one rainy forecast can go actually
shopping with Luke one forecast pain but
it has a mobile capacitive 2500 United
places 10 movies for customer visit 396
places by 2018 90 which is already been
mentioned or previous over-committing my
question around is presumably ruptured
significant one Railly is very same
outfits by one school in a recent
application chairman just on the fight
an order if members are going to mention
this PokePark up got an issue the other
is a smart imagination of our employment
that it's very far does in a difficult
position nope no t cancer and cancer at
issue here
it's not in our catchment area
so
I'm
I'm just hungry this legislation
advice if this is an opportunist it will
be other contributions from other
developments and heavy Council has not
to the education problem there's no salt
and calling you cause injury Thank You
Jeremiah power focus our attention to
for the psycho firm pirate alien and the
right woman what's important to raise an
issue the answer your question also says
that kind of 4.8 Foley that's our
position with you danced as it says
council that requesting a contribution
to the fire action finish my test wasn't
my question of it my customers around
the recent devastating in fact that we
are quoted in a recent application which
was something like 30 on places 9 for
what the school that I've ever mention
again of 22 for young lady school so my
question was about of grouping is it
just those two schools need be first to
and why are we suddenly got a deficit
386 places when we end pre asleep the
moment since it's going there too right
clever something but the biggest don't
I think it's something we should make
the unique of inquiry by various
counties I so when about but not sure
that it's an issue we can settle tonight
that's the plan into in terms of the way
in which such the deficits of school
places etc or anything other sir to
consider course from on purpose of the
prosperity which is in place by this
council is to actually advise those
farmers of the needs that they all have
to accommodate not sure that will be in
the highest priority in terms of
providing those additional places as
well and the development may or may not
be built out you should not get mcd
force if I might just come back with me
and then it doesn't relate Miss 02 this
application but it might because there
is no funding in this application I had
little bit following noting the book
required for the county part in the
previous application there was a funding
amount agreed on that episode
as opposed to something people it's
later that appears to be a deficit of
386 that's my capsule which is why i
said this may recall us on inquiry a
county able to understand exactly why
don't see it as a challenge but i don't
think this is something which is an
interior consideration given the penalty
taking lot our school a contribution
state to love that kept you see the
present thank you for your explanation I
wasn't suggesting it wasn't a terror
consideration i was just seeking
clarification there's committee member
myself what's your availability so
handsome i see you suppose Thank You mr.
championing because Mike's obviously
quite away away I think we've all heard
that the majority of the committee seem
to be in approving of this in principle
of the actual housing usage on this site
I must admit I on as well and also very
pleased to see that we get an affordable
housing which was well needed in this
area but the material problem of access
seems to have been not clarified enough
for me to be comfortable with this
application as it stands we have
if you go back place to the other side
we have three bits shows the highway or
passage there is no indication that i
can find out how much that in lithic and
how much is double with it is a long
passage that people could fasten down
we've got the three day could someone
tell me how much of that is double with
custom parts each other and then but
that'll it cannot be passed by two
vehicles chair is probably easiest
explainable on this guy right here which
is an amalgam of three larger ones you
see here because we explain the first
stretch of the Rio is improved as is the
last since this middle section in here
which stays as it currently is what you
see where singled some generous single
in terms of it takes a lot of reasoning
the two cars from the pasture right so
basically we're promoting a bottleneck
one other my concern with this access is
not only for vehicle traffic but we're
putting on a housing estate with a
portable family presumably it's three
four five bedroom properties they're
very much children in that property and
those children are very likely to want
to travel to our schools and leave there
is a bus stop just at the end of here is
this road on the main road now I would
say that if I was living there I would
expect my child's be able to walk safely
down that road to the custom especially
if there are secondary
I cannot see if that is impossible on
the layout that we have in front of us
it says here that roughly sixty percent
of journeys are taken to work by car we
are trying to encourage our youngsters
to be fit and healthy and to walk to
work that would mean that everyone on
that site will need a car to safely get
their children from the site to the main
road and that is of concern I wonder if
this any provision to put a footpath in
the issue pedestrian safety having heard
that being mentioned thank you when you
think under put your thumb their patient
and perdition 18 says that the loan
improvements that are required by my
County and provide adequate access
almost always this roadway and that
building code vision is for a shared
cycle footwear on these design can go to
be millimeters and there's some some
some up there I think that is a mission
obviously we need to work very hard with
develops of an attorney so County onto
my shoulder and I think a local
authority in terms of number
that talent is paying for health and we
should be encouraging walking with
Hospital cycle municipal and and that
something we need to make sure that the
moment is wide enough for her vehicle
and where possible and the safe house
road at the cycle and the footwork
obviously we want to show that the
developerworks funny story exactly with
plenty else to use them now this come
back on that mr. chairman if I may you
know I take it the answer that it no at
the moment on the application as it
stands in front of us which is one we
have to assess is that the provision is
not there because from what I'm hearing
is we can have a lorry going down there
or we can have a car on the scientists
and nothing they can't meet and they
can't pass each other on a large tract
of that highway which surely should have
been resolved before that came to this
committee thank you thank you this maze
of via the the root of my intern
question which was pretty disparity
officer space whether these are matters
which would be best address once the
final layout of this development is now
that we have at the mother
this is indicative I was initially
puzzled oh I submit by some of the
responses oh we're also pleased in that
I certainly had not seen an indicative
that we have to talk myself I'm not sure
what the board members said but that
happen Wood River City touch that's a
better Thank You mr. chairman I would
like to clarify this it i read through
this report in sunday though there is a
proposed pedestrian footpath from cyber
launch to the site there can be no no
this room footpath along a single
carriageway and there is no is nothing
said about a foot I'll the 74 meters
from the junction of the rocky road to
whip rates where the rodents near why if
there's the height of my question was
happy councillors seeing a indicated
design of the development previously I
have seen report and I've seen the plan
and i visited the site myself that's all
I've seen but i have read report in
detail on one outside open
way I think it's absolutely correct
welcome i got with your case but my life
my question and its officers would be so
my question would be of these mesas
which can be addressed with the full
application and likely challenge from
the motors which really is our patient
call you with access as part of that
outlined situations every the matter
will be additional reserve motor and
that's why we're seeing the conditions
that obviously we will only
conservatively we get right this moment
right to those highways that's why we
looked at issue of a moment vision 17
and it's 18 will actually come forward
with with an increase of this the fine
print of you and which all we get are
moaning agreements that we can to ensure
that we get a safe access and egress on
the northeast side and through this this
piece of romaine on to the main highway
and obviously looking at the practice
charter service waters nosotros
materials and obviously if if the
developer can't discharge that condition
and that obviously need diversity
effectively promote their to go ahead so
ringtones and we're not going to an
irate and efficient discharger
conditions doesn't meet the requirements
on progress as counsel and the phone
authority thank you a brief cancer ward
what should come back can be fully
Felicia forever
yes it is free I just want to again
we're looking at a 16-9 779 it would
we'll get you referring to highlight and
prudence again where are the three major
song for white long eastern side of the
carriageway it's south of Marion house
and it goes to the whole leg the whole
way through to the development that
correct okay so just but there's nothing
beyond beyond beyond area coming in from
the top of the access road for poppy
Robin so we are we talking about that
particular part of a shed side before
life is there any provision for
pedestrians and cyclists being on that
going up to hockey right but that's that
duffel I'm looking at the only site from
Marion house which is right in the
middle which is in the bottle neck area
but there doesn't seem to be anything
cited from Marion house up to let's anal
flawed your witness then I please have
fun
you
that's correct just one parent
current electrician but are we in a
position to condition at this moment
that the developer looks adding proving
that so that it least there is access
about cycle and pedestrian from Marion
house through to a brace please note the
Holy Word within a site and effective
excited that my line and obviously
that's um Federline any additional
warranty would fall outside of my area
and so in them so exactly support of the
road early as in terms of week as it is
although in a family of four justices
briefly please for the sake of clarity I
would be able to agree the
recommendations of there before us
should we be able to have terminology
that say the transport lean from the
rocky road to the proposed development
the other standard that MIT that allows
the appropriate agency demons behind
ways to agree that there is appropriate
access more vehicles
and pedestrians I would need to see that
that is agreed by ID appropriate bodies
I think shared access is a bit
misleading point i think the body misses
articles on the covers of course so far
is the comedy set out of paragraph 4.4
which says from a high rate russell
perspective the impact of the proposal
is acceptable to highly suggest the
following education and conditions from
the essex county council from the
transportation point view and that's
that point and then the petitions we
have picked up through the phone through
the recommendation are in line with what
s pentecostal have required to do so
Milton has been just already and that
statement is very clear within this
decision with weight and the conditions
that we've put on relating to injunction
or main improvements are in line with
why suspect castle have required to do
to make a sunlit I would point out two
letters that we are rather high found by
basics and highways recommendations and
not really in a position to question
though you know we may wish to our
government agency other applications in
the past is not so yeah we have devoted
to do that get us a wall very briefly
again police would it be possible to
defer to send this back to highways
because we are not satisfied with
is that has a redneck station right
there under file itself is where we've
reached a any impulse in terms of just
being a a suit for service very handsome
hungry so in email terms there is no we
just go and run in circles they would
come up with the same recommendation and
we be here next next next month with
that same recommendation in other terms
I think can ensure that some we deal
with those petitions to ensure where
possible we can get the wrong as long as
we can get it and to ensure that the
posse places are correct and to ensure
that the road services are correct
ensure that a better a warfare a cyclist
and a road runner but a car user feels
safe on that road together so that's the
case of vs I think working with the
developer and a few developers to make
sure we get that correct so I don't
think it's a matter if it's worth I
think that the conditions are second on
the on recommendation will do all those
concerns
absolutely necessary been waiting up
neighbors organelles that now but have
you set out the order of play initially
everyone loves Oh designs as outlined
what the concern is but at this moment
in time not given us enough confidence
in the mechanism by which that will
happen and I think that's the crux of
the matter we there are some limitations
the wicked aside we've heard that
highways are content we've heard that we
as a council need to work to achieve the
best solution but I believe that the
words I was working with the developer
to achieve the best solution or just
that little bit to worry at the moment
whereas achieving what we want which is
a safe passage possible across that
particular single character edge area
it's just the word support to worry
because I believe there is within the
apt description that we've been given
enough ambiguity for a developer for the
developer so to send Connor anything
about it take it or leave it I wouldn't
be happy with that clearly developers
hearing the discussion and understands
where we're coming from as part of dance
routines but I'm just looking for some
further hard [ __ ] of our terminology
place
terminology no one likes of his 18 Simon
on development so my own terms phone
lock we want to use one sounds like
we'll work with that very clear very
clear ambition commit like buying a
policy and that says fast present moment
that post all would make improvement
because it likewise working are shown
that this one up for we shall be
provided entirely by the Thomas
expensing provisions of shared cycling
for quite funny since I'm very very many
millimeters roasting at the south of
marine how to fight a definitive link to
the proposed element and I'm condition
seventies volleyball discuss about the
amendment no details of those are
significant role in roadway improvements
it's not worry we face out there and
it's a discharging a condition that
would be which would be hot with a local
high mobility as the council to ensure
let's do that pre-shift shark directly
to choose your the Robo produced by this
development these parasites to the shore
safety and security of road users both
on the foot and bicycle and and in the
funnel thank you Harris is showing they
keep your potion ish thank you all right
the reason I didn't need to say right
okay okay before I start Calliope Taylor
Heineken interesting which process from
school got none now I only say that
because these report nations that were
part of his primary school with the main
action area school
we have no capacity for priming my
colleagues of making secondary all your
grace is political I'm just have to I
think the public schools invention these
paper with its own reach a situation
there is no contribution of eyes there
is no public literacy that thankfully my
my concern is and his new touched on by
my colleagues and I have spoken to mr.
Strack who's got an answer from Essex
educational authority they offer a
contribution for 47,000 185 pounds for
early years and childcare is going to be
another job for your County adding
spoken to most of the primary schools in
writing the last 48 hours I do not have
a capacity to take the children that are
currently on the wrist potentially while
they have covered to a big development
engineers award but completely forgotten
about car from walls development is you
70 properties about a hundred reality
little Francis school so I think that
your capacities as can be answered unity
of Maggie's allocated exit education
whether they really found their homework
on the primary school cover as well as
the the junior school so I have spoken
to mostly primary schools in about 48
hours and they don't sink the other so
today show you the numbers they'll be in
predicting which makes me question some
of the other numbers are being predicted
whereby the estimate ease is 2.4
residence for development these are four
or five pages developments and other
start to question emanation 2.45 p.m.
County dificil doesn't i added and last
but not least people smile at the
college of club emoji aspects of traffic
and congestion but i think it may sold
itself there was a concern expressed
about the vibration of heavy lorries to
all the properties but from here my
colleagues at highlighting are done
theater be moving very fast anyway but i
would be probably do so and
I would like to do have some sort of
conditional what would happen or how we
are going to control these lorries and
stop the vibration of these be trusted
against this new buildings thank you Jim
thinking just to clarify the members of
the public and any matters that may not
be aware my County Division is for props
itself I think it would be probably
those educated for me to undertake
queries or be helpful but when i come
back gentlemen I'm very very happy to
join Joe slippers very honorably kind I
think they would need to initiate it yes
sir with it Sasori see if I can just
come back on a couple of points the last
but the idea effect on my city building
see from the county's expert he's
concerned that some demolition oversized
equals what equals I think building
strike how would anticipate that will
work person in construction management
plan the idea being that already comes
in and probably have excellent either
sides as the driver too busy is gonna
hit something whatever salvation may go
show that rather an occasion
with the damn so light pretty clear that
could be managed I can't help members
with the full workings of how the
education Authority violence seem but I
think it's fair to say they have to
avoid double counting members have
mentioned the cultural waterside I know
through the previous appearance on cyber
code the education Authority accounted
for those numbers many years ago it was
79 permission and since that time
they're always allow for it such a tool
out but now they would effectively be
double counting and I think the way it
works they have a central reserve or
pops if you like for eccentric the idea
is these new developments replenish that
pot they plan from that so you can see
directly the money that you created
through this thing go straight into the
soul is obviously the build period that
joins after them occupied all my
instructors be provided us so I think
the way they manager avoiding double
counting and which is why they updated
their comments you'll see in a reporter
is they're working to replenish your
resource I don't know if that helps
members or possibly clouds it but that
that is why you don't always see this
development that I'm all topped up to
slice it because the authority work to a
very well-respected formula and they get
their numbers through that and that's
why perhaps a headmaster might say he
hasn't had capacity that his
organization will be planning likely
pass
strategically in the background they
constructed clear exhalation I think
touched on below saying regarding the
forward language students off from our
core strategy necessary thank you I do a
break out the conversation Mr strange
but I do think we should highlight this
issue because if this is the case and
they haggle we're covered none of
minutes seem to know anything about me
for playing certainly not it with
Francis anyway and if it had been
accounted for we don't really do have a
problem because we already have a
deficit actually I will consult with the
relevant county members and we load our
scene with counselor cooking as you can
counsel the portfolio holder figure
right when I say there being no motion
school for five little city pounds and
forwards the recommendations offices has
printed for with the amendment country
so so education 17 moving and the words
money in the voice and prior to
commencement and early the developments
on page of the site when I remember the
most accepted evolutionary duration of
protection for the revolution continues
and an additional additional issue
restricting turret and deliveries to the
site outside and typically occur only at
five below which will be usually eight
o'clock to 1 30 and then it's normally
and help us to 20 z
I contend with the tax amendment is just
announced and therefore else members to
vote those in favor please indicate of
the recommendation is printed as amended
by those two amendments just measure and
those in favor please indicate
those you guys
like she's--hair it a nice to three
times it instead my question now is to
allow it to buy some plates c7 cancer
person which in the first place would've
left in China
who
how many more members of the public
wishing to the very welcome to side
course that you like the appropriate to
carry on conversations outside
right isolates the incredible you
already knew Jim this application is to
the sign of a semi-detached house
located on the southern side around
actually in the recently extended out of
the rain translation error patient
portal floor council and the protocol to
death and being a member of this council
you can see the photographs this just
shows you the existing situation the
society is this unit here he receive the
existing gate for the members interests
at this stage is to note the existing
wall and the fact that it is set from
representations you'll see on the
addendum the adjoining neighbor recalls
that this action was a reconstruction
where by a number of residents gave up
art there frontage tulalip I way to be
widened so what the property is very
attractive and outstanding lots of
original features the wall was actually
a reconstruction itself now if we can
see the historic Street View what the
applicants trying to do is to go back to
restore the slender of the street here
we see before the highways realigned and
approved it now on that scientist second
unit there loafers it's step in the wall
and the height of the piers and the
cappings and the railings between that
are in the detail from the neighbor next
door on the addendum the applicants
seeking to bring back is this kind of
approach
he's excited to see environment and to
reflect designer characters this time
around about 1903 if we could see the
layout peace plan for the application if
we look at the top here hopefully that's
clear enough you'll see this for joining
yourself here's the highway of existing
crossing in this top corner it is paving
with a central flower better than
driving on this side or the applicant
wishes to do is just slightly take away
some of that wall the report slightly
error because it's assumed that it was a
reconstruction of all but the atkins
pointed out that's not the case is the
knowledge point later the later been for
that and construct easily change provide
this surfacing but also a new surface of
a to the pathway from the gate which
would be kept leading to my house and
you see it's piling it would insult
Eiling was opposed to the concrete
nineteen sixties crazy paving when I
think the area's redesigned in the
cities now the landscaping here instead
of being a central part of season or for
under the bay to the house of both side
part fight into the side frontage the
gentleman's of the elevations please
what the outcome proposes through the
wall is to sense you keep that power orb
of construct this here and this one and
provide the ratings between appears here
now what the actives are pointed out
that the draft has actually been
slightly Arabic because he wishes to
keep the step I was laboring on with the
photographs what you'll see here is a
straight line through what the applicant
proposed is touching retainers in green
site appears only today time appears we
saw in this photo photo for much higher
more substantial but you will see from
the sentiment of the report that offices
and the county advisor
feel the reinstatement of this detail
enhances it uplifts the conservation
area which is our main duty and
responsibility and our land bases in the
application is recommended approval now
since the report has been published the
applicant has put forward the various
materials and there's a Simon to the
conditions condition tone which require
it to be billed strip pinochle boring
election just very safe container set
future condition three whereas we ask
for the painting samples to be provided
the applicant have opal a few days I've
done samples and we've got a pretty
special he was called coated black lime
stone paving and so that we don't need
now to submit those with blue the green
those on condition for which sort the
choice of mortar mix the we can
apprehend that we would be using a lie
enforcer in that there are now they are
people have to submit successive details
with our sequence details so I'd like to
be able to adjust those conditions you
may / improve it to reflect what is
being agreed basically a piece of
working duplication so the
recommendation sharing is a proof or
subject to the site and Evans and those
changes from details that are accepted
Thank You jokes we have no coverage
these all members of educating isn't
done gasps of all I would like to
compliment the applicant on what is
trying to do and I'm a definitely
proposed you have this recommendation of
improvements we we do those surveyed
agree yes where those amendments were
any other than this issue to Cancer
Center yes I can just point to education
the main parking to be parking it will
let you corner wall with the water
batteries chairman hopefully this clears
and the door this is a drop by very
little sick people form and I cover
drying here the idea being that
rainwater is captured before it goes
across the highway the applicant is
anticipated that and would be providing
strange here
Thank You strokes to myself there's a
real ocean quality relax in there dudes
those it straight into planning because
I'm the committee development rights
outside of the conservation area being
from block paid on the basis that
capture the rainwater in some way avoid
it but across the highway so so
confining has started to deal with this
then if nervous wish to judge if you got
a second with you emotionally forgiving
casa six seconds those in favor please
indicate desi lens which face we come
the end of business operations they
could be revenge